[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara Hellweg guten Abend ihnen allen
ungewohnte Kombi heute erste Advent und
Fußball-WM Christian für die deutschen
wird gleich Ernst wobei sich die Lage
etwas entspannt hat guten Abend das sind
die Themen von heute
in einer Stunde geht's los Mannschaft
und Fans fiebern dem Spiel gegen Spanien
entgegen
Wut wegen Null covic-politik in China
protestieren immer mehr Menschen gegen
die Regierung
katastrophale Lebensbedingungen Kiews
Bürgermeister Klitschko bittet um
Unterstützung für die notleidenden
Menschen
[Musik]
wir beginnen direkt in Doha da läuft
sich die deutsche Mannschaft langsam
warm ein bisschen Druck ist ja raus
durch den Sieg von Costa Rica gegen sind
schon alle ein bisschen auch im
tunnelfakt ist selbst bei einer
Niederlage jeden Spanien wird die
deutsche Mannschaft nicht vorzeitig
ausscheiden und kann die Achtelfinal
Chance waren hätte aber das Weiterkommen
am letzten Gruppenspieltag nicht mehr
selbst in der Hand das Team von Hansi
Flick ist vor etwa einer Viertelstunde
in Alcor angekommen Entschlossenheit und
Mut hat der Bundestrainer gefordert die
Stimmung sei gut und die große Frage ist
wer darf nun von Beginn an auflaufen ist
für uns im Stadion was kannst du uns zur
Aufstellung sagen
also der Bundestrainer nimmt zwei
Veränderungen vor einem Vergleich zum
Spiel gegen Japan in der Abwehr kommt
Tilo Kehrer rein Niklas süle rückt dafür
in die Mitte bildet die
Innenverteidigung mit Antonio Rüdiger
und davor wird spannend Leon Goretzka
kommt neu ins Team und Spiel zusammen
mit Josua Kimmich auf der Doppel 6 und
das können die beiden natürlich aus dem
Verein davor dann Ilkay Gündogan der
bleibt also in der Mannschaft war auch
einer der stärksten gegen Japan und ja
aus dieser Position das wissen wir von
ManCity ist der durchaus Tor gefährlich
und dann wiederum davor für Kai havertz
der hat vorher den Sturm begleitet und
jetzt ist es dann Thomas Müller der ganz
vorne auf der neuen spielt also eine
Veränderung zwei Veränderungen durchaus
mutig was Hansi fliegt hier gegen
Spanien spielen lässt ganz klar auf
jeden Fall heute ein Sieg gegen Spanien
und Deutschland wäre wieder richtig gut
im Rennen hätte es in der eigenen Hand
wir sind sehr gespannt hier im Stadion
von Alcor 20 Uhr geht's los ganz schön
viel los schon bei dir danke Sven und
hier gibt es auch gleich mehr vom Sport
von mir jetzt schauen wir erstmal nach
China wer dort die kommunistische
Führung kritisiert muss mit drastischen
Konsequenzen rechnen trotzdem gehen
landesweit immer mehr Menschen auf die
Straße aus Wut und aus Protest gegen die
strikten corona-maßnahmen Miriam Steiner
berichtet
wir wollen keine corona-tests wir wollen
Freiheit wie hier in Peking versammeln
sich die Menschen heute Abend in vielen
Städten was als Protest gegen die
strengen corona-regeln begann weitet
sich aus
wir haben Menschenwürde wir sind
Menschen wir sind Chinesen wir brauchen
Rechtsstaatlichkeit Rechtsstaatlichkeit
[Musik]
ein Auslöser für den Protest ist ein
Wohnungsbrand im Nordwesten des Landes
mindestens zehn Menschen kamen dabei ums
Leben das löste einen Sturm der
Entrüstung aus viele glauben dass die
Menschen wegen corona-absperrungen nicht
aus dem brennenden Haus kam Millionen im
Land sitzen selbst im Lockdown und
fragen sich ob sie bei einem Feuer oder
Erdbeben rauskämmen das Besondere das im
Moment halt wirklich alle betroffen sind
ja es ist nicht nur die Bevölkerung
betroffen sind genauso auch die Kader
betroffen werden
die Polizei betroffen ist es wirklich
die ganze Bevölkerung betroffen
auch an der teamchor Universität einer
der Eliteunis des Landes versammeln sich
die Studierenden sie alle eint die Wut
gegen die strikten corona-regeln jeden
Tag meldet China eine neue Rekordzahl an
infizierten die Staatsführung hält stur
an den extremen Maßnahmen fest die
Menschen wären sich die weißen Blätter
sie
werbeteste würde was draufstehen werden
sie als polizeibeweis noch gefährlicher
es ist schon so in China gefährlich
genug zum Protestieren auf die Straße zu
gehen
eine seltene Meinungsäußerung in einem
Land ohne Meinungsfreiheit
in die Ukraine dort wird weiter gekämpft
doch schon jetzt ist klar der
Wiederaufbau nach dem Krieg wird lange
dauern und sehr teuer stand jetzt soll
er mindestens 349 Milliarden Euro kosten
das hat die ukrainische Regierung
gemeinsam mit EU-Kommission und Weltbank
berechnet morgen reist hier ist
Bürgermeister Klitschko nach Brüssel um
die Europäer um Unterstützung zu bitten
Hannah Hebestreit
auf dem Markt in Odessa ist das Angebot
auch mitten im Krieg noch überraschend
groß aber immer weniger Menschen kommen
hierher den Händlern fehlen die
Einnahmen
viele meiner Kunden sind gar nicht mehr
in der Stadt die Preise steigen ständig
das kann sich kaum noch jemand leisten
wir machen nur noch ein Drittel des
früheren Umsatzes
mangelnde Kaufkraft immer wieder
Angriffe und die massiv eingeschränkte
Stromversorgung vor seiner Abreise zu
einer europäischen Wirtschaftskonferenz
morgen in Brüssel bitte Kiews
Bürgermeister Klitschko um weitere
Hilfen der europäischen Nachbarn
wir haben Pläne statt wieder aufzubauen
und statt zu entwickeln und
deswegen wir sind bereit sehr viele
Projekte zu präsentieren an unsere
Partner und sehr dankbar an unsere
Partner für Unterstützung in den
Markthallen von Odessa ist ein Produkt
ganz besonders gefragt
batteriebetriebene Lampen die
funktionieren wenn der Strom mal wieder
ausfällt
die Kirchen in Deutschland haben mit
Gottesdiensten ihre traditionellen
Spendenaktionen zur Weihnachtszeit
begonnen dass evangelische Hilfswerk
Brot für die Welt startete seine
Kampagne in Oldenburg Motto in diesem
Jahr eine Welt ein Klima eine Zukunft in
Trier eröffnete das katholische
Lateinamerika Hilfswerk adveniert seine
Aktion unter dem Leitspruch gesund sein
fördern
die Bewohner der Insel Ischia in
Süditalien kämpfen weiter mit den Folgen
eines schweren Erdrutsches mindestens
fünf Menschen kamen ums Leben darunter
auch ein kleines Mädchen die ganze Nacht
durchsuchten Helfer im Schlamm nach
Vermissten doch von mehreren Einwohnern
fehlt noch jede Spur ein Hang war
gestern nach einem Unwetter ins Rutschen
geraten
50 Minuten noch dann ist Anpfiff gegen
Spanien die Spannung und Vorfreude
steigt wie sich die Fans aufs Spiel
einstimmen vor Ort in Doha und
hierzulande das zeigen an seinem Stern
und golini
im knapp einer Stunde wird im fernen
Katar angepfiffen Deutschlands Kneipen
Deutschlands Fans bereiten sich vor beim
Spiel wird es hier im Sixties in Mainz
ganz anders aussehen nämlich voll ja wir
sind auf jeden Fall komplett aus
reserviert
Nervosität Vorfreude Zuversicht ein
bisschen von allem vor dem so wichtigen
Spiel den Klassiker gegen Spanien ich
glaube die deutsche würden sich diesmal
nicht packen für Deutschland
wie das ausgeht ist man relativ egal ich
nehme auch ein 1,000 Bauchgefühl würde
ich sagen Spanien gewinnen WM im Winter
mit Glühwein es ist vieles anders und
schwierig manches ist aber auch wie
immer ich denke mal dass ich mit gucke
aber wenn es so aufregend wird dann gehe
ich viel Druck also für die Nationalelf
entfernen Katar
Deutschland gegen Spanien Fan kicken in
Doha bei 32 Grad der ehemalige
barcelona-star und Spanien Weltmeister
schahi gibt Ihnen Tipps die Wünsche der
Deutschen für heute Abend Leidenschaft
Herz Mannschaftsgeist mittlerweile hoffe
ich dass sich die Truppe zusammengerauft
hat und mal richtig angefaucht hat im
besten Sinne ich hoffe natürlich auf
einen Sieg der Deutschen aber er
pessimistisch gestimmt gut der wm-lehrer
der Fehler ein wenig aber trotzdem fühle
man sich wohl
also wir lieben den Sport und darum sind
wir hier am Ende des fan-turniers siegt
Deutschland übrigens mit 15 zu 11 ein
gutes Zeichen
gutes Zeichen den ersten großen Jubel
gab es am Mittag und den hat Costa Rica
ausgelöst ne viele echt unerwartet vom
Außenseiter zum Matchwinner Costa Rica
hat gezeigt was möglich ist wenn man an
sich glaubt fast eine kleine
Wiederauferstehung nach dem 0:7 gegen
Spanien nun eins zu null gegen die hoch
gehandelten Japaner wir leben noch so
Trainer Suarez
überwältigt von Glücksgefühlen die
krassen Außenseiter aus Costa Rica mit
ihrem ersten Torschuss in diesem Turnier
erzielen sie nach 81 Minuten den 1:0
Siegtreffer Japans bis dahin überhaupt
nicht geforderte Defensive viel zu
sorglos gegen Fulda unverhoff macht
doppelt glücklich zumal die Deutschland
Bezwinger aus Japan auch ihre letzte
große Chance vergeben der von
Frankfurter kamada geschossen der Ball
wird abgewehrt flippert noch ein wenig
durch den Strafraum Ehe Costa Rica
torwartner was sicher zugreift ein
herberückschlag für Japan
und das gilt auch für Belgien denn
Marokko gewann unerwartet 2:0 und
verderbt dem ewigen Geheimfavoriten den
vorzeitigen Einzug in die Ko-Runde
Kanada ist das zweite Mannschaft nach
Katar ausgeschieden eins zu vier gegen
Vize-Weltmeister Kroatien und noch ein
tolles Comeback im Wintersport bei den
alpinen Abfahrt in Lake Louis Kanada
Thomas Dreesen belegt in seinem ersten
Weltcup-Rennen seit zweieinhalb Jahren
mit nur einer Sekunde Rückstand einen
starken achten Platz und knackte auf
Anhieb die WM Normen des DSV beachtlich
insgesamt fünf Deutsche unter den Top 30
auftakt-sieger Alexander Arnold Kiel der
aus Norwegen und den super-gi gibt es
8:30 Uhr im ZDF Livestream
sportstudio.de aber gleich geht's
natürlich hier weiter mit Fußball genau
und vorher noch das Wetter im Nordosten
gibt es morgen etwas Sonne sonst ist es
trüb im Westen regnet es zeitweise
leicht die Temperatur erreicht 3 bis 11
Grad und auch die nächsten Tage bleiben
meist trüb und es wird etwas kälter das
heute journal mit Marietta Slomka in der
Halbzeitpause um viertel vor neun morgen
übernimmt ihr Jana pareigis wir sagen
tschüss und wünschen einen spannenden
Fußballabend auf bald
[Musik]